well you look good thank you yeah you
look i could see why you modeled
professionally made a fortune how old
were you when you started modeling i was
15 years old
15. where where did you grow up la and
when you're in la your mother just
looked at you and knew right away you
were that good-looking and said i'm
going to put you in modeling my mother
looked at me and had no idea that i was
a model my mom was a medical
photographer and part-time she would
take pictures of women that wanted to
model right and i would hold the bounce
card and and and check her lighting for
her as her little 12 year old assistant
so how do you get into modeling a girl
came up to me on the first day of school
and was like you look like a model and i
was like what she was the first person
to ever tell me that how does one go
about becoming a model i don't
understand how you make that job well i
waited she discovered me when i was 13.
i waited until the 11th grade when i was
15. and i went to a bunch of agencies
and you walked around with a a picture
of yourself i walked around with some
snapshots that my mom took of me so you
must have known you were good-looking
and boys must have started paying
attention boys still we're not paying
attention you have to understand that
model does not necessarily mean
beautiful alluring or mature beautiful
boy when i was younger i was more of a
high fashion model look so it was a
little more quirky and more odd more
interesting and being a black woman i
remember when you started modeling it
was not really that common for a black
woman to be a model and maybe there's
only one black model that's allowed to
be successful exactly i walked into the
agencies and a lot of them were like oh
we only have
i'm sorry we already have a
a black model sorry so it's almost
impossible so if someone would have said
to you that you would have made a
fortune as a model
you would have laughed because at that
time it would have been questionable
whether you could even get work yeah i
would have laughed so you walk in i walk
in to the one that said yes who is that
la models and are you grateful to them
because they didn't say we have already
one black model i'm super grateful i'm
probably sitting in front of you now
because of them although they did tell
me i wasn't photogenic but that and that
i should do runway so i started off with
runway with them how do you learn how to
do that that walk on the runway what is
that all about studied i studied i
studied i studied and i've seen
documentaries and stuff on you and how
you studied and like really you studied
what the women did i studied i went to
the fashion library in los angeles and
like was obsessed with tape and i'd
watch tape of girls from the 80s and
like and just really like study them 70s
too there is something to study about
why some people break out and some don't
yes so what was the secret that you
somehow are more interesting i think the
secret for me was a lot of research so
like when i went to paris for the very
first time instead of going to college i
went to paris i got accepted at every
college i applied to i wanted to i
wanted to be a writer yes i wanted to be
a writer and a producer for film and
television you didn't go to college no i
didn't i got accepted to all of them but
i got discovered to go to paris at the
last two weeks before my first day of
college i got discovered and you said
screw college i can make a fortune doing
this model no i said oh my god this is
the craziest decision of my life what am
i going to do i don't know what to do i
talked to my mom my mom said follow your
heart i support you and whatever what
could a girl make
walking the runways of europe can she
make how much can you make a day doing
that well back in my day um
somewhat some of the top girls are
making ten thousand dollars a fashion
show wow and so you do five a day you do
about 25 per s per city so add up milan
paris new york and then maybe a little
bit of lunch but you can pull in 50 g's
a day yeah oh my god you must have been
going berserk yeah i was doing pretty
well